[Music]
my name is Jamie Thomson I am an
engineer for a company called Dunn home
B in the UK
we're a big GCP customer and we've been
using data proc for a couple of years
now
so really today's session could be
retitled our journey with Google cloud
platform I'm going to talk a lot about
what we've been using how we do a lot of
the stuff that we do especially
especially using data proc and I'm quite
looking example here representing the
team I work for which in within done
humble is a team called core technology
it's our job to provide infrastructure
and services to the rest of the company
a bunch of very smart people and I'm
lucky enough to be here representing
that team of about 25 people today so
what do duncan be do exactly it's once
you just level set it so when people
understand what it is we do because that
will feed into the rest of the
presentation so we're a customer first
data science company and we believe if
we if our customers if our clients put
their customers first and through that
they can drive loyalty through that they
can drive long-term sustainable profit
we've been doing this for about 25 years
now long before the term big data they
were being kind and we're wholly owned
by Tesco in the UK and they are also our
biggest client and we've been behind the
success of Tesco's Clubcard loyalty
scheme for some years now so a high
level we do a couple of things for our
clients so firstly we provide
consultancy over the data that they
provide to us clients will ask us
tactical questions like why am i losing
very price-sensitive customers to my
competitor or they'll ask you strategic
questions such as what would be my best
media strategy for return on investment
of the next four to five years and in
both of these cases we try and answer
those questions through a combination of
data and data science over the past 25
years we've built and we've had a lot of
experience and as you can imagine we
come across some common problems quite a
lot we built up a software portfolio to
address some of these issues so we have
products around category management
and promotions and media so we have a
category of sallman offering which helps
typically our retail clients decide what
to put on the shelves I mean you're
offering helps people helps our clients
decide who to target with offers and
when to do that and pricing promotions
helps our clients make decisions such as
watching what promotions should buy
should I be putting on in my stores in a
couple of months things like that so
this slight short slide covers where we
work so we're all over the globe we've
got 78 retail clients and over 2000
customer consumer packaged goods clients
we manage data for about 800 customers
of our retailers and we've got a data
corpus of about forty four billion
baskets that our data scientists work
against every day so just want to go in
in a nutshell what don't be kind of do
and how we work so clients will send
their data to us and when they do that
we will assign a team of data engineers
to that clients too and it's their
responsibility to take that incoming
data transform it into what we call a
common data model that and can be used
by our products and by our services by
our data scientists throughout the
company so that's a role of our data
engineers we have products which consume
that carbon data model and we have data
scientists which provide consultancy
services running algorithms over that
common data model and finally we
delivered services back to our clients
in the way of api's and data
visualizations so I said we've been in
this business for about 25 years but our
business has been changing over the past
five years
we typically sought very long multi-year
engagements with our clients but we're
finding that was becoming really
unpalatable to a lot of our prospects
clients really wanted shorter
engagements with us and there was a lot
looking for a lot more flexibility of
how we can actually provide what we
provide our technology stack was very
proprietary
it was Best of Breed which is another
word for saying it was very expensive
and we we hosted all of our own
infrastructure as well so we have four
data centers two in the u.s. two in the
UK and we've got about four petabytes of
data stored across those data centers so
we made a conscious decision to move to
open source and cloud open source
because it was cheaper much more
flexibility and cloud because buying
hardware for short client engagements
was never really going to be feasible
for us so we're about halfway through
our journey of migrate and all our
clients to the cloud and we hope to in a
couple of years fully deprecate all of
our data centers the technology stack
that we're using is what I put on the
slide here so we were using Oracle
Exadata for storage SAS for data
processing and redwood Chronicle as our
scheduling till all three of which Best
of Breed very expensive and they cost us
a lot of money so we made it through a
program of work which we call tetra
newell we made these we made a lot of
changes to how we deliver stuff and the
tools that we use to actually deliver it
so we made a big investment in Python as
I chosen language for our data
scientists we made a big bet on Apache
spark we adopted spark when it was
around with a 1.6 version and I think
since then it's proved to be the kind of
de facto tool for big data processing so
we're very pleased with what sparks the
interest we have adopted Apache airflow
as as a workflow tool for those that
don't know this is a scheduling workflow
tool that came out of Airbnb and we use
Jupiter notebooks our data scientist
used oops our notebooks we provide them
to us as part of the infrastructure that
I'm going to demonstrate today and we
made a big big bet on terraform as well
terraform is a tool from a company
called Hoshi Corp and what it does is
allow you to manage your infrastructure
as code so we're using that to deploy
everything it's going to be talking
about today and I've got a demo a little
bit later that will talk a little bit
about that we're using graph on ax
another open source tool for visualizing
monitoring data and finally the other
big bet that we made was choosing GCP
provoke cloud provider and as part of
that data proc has become the
cornerstone of everything that we're
doing on GCP and we've been using that
for about two years now
so when you're always providing don't
hum being with quite a lot of benefits
we have modern tech stack the things I
was just talking about massive reduction
in cost mostly through the lack that
we'd have to pay license fees anymore
better provisioning we can provision
infrastructure for new clients a lot
quicker than we can ever do that and
doing the past much more scalable
platform we can down up and down it down
as we need we have a lot more hosting
options we previously all we could do
was host clients in the US or the UK we
can now help them where other Google
have got an data center much more robust
security we build on top of Google's
investments in that area and we and we
benefit from that and we're also finding
a lot more opportunities from this as
well there's a lot more clients out
there who want to be on the cloud and
want to come on this journey with us and
it's providing a lot more partnering
opportunities for us as well ok so
that's enough spiel about what doesn't
be actually do what we are I want to
talk more now about the real meat of
what we're doing and this is something
we call transient data prop clusters
Google refer to is ephemeral data proc
clusters I don't know why we call it
something different but transient data
clusters is how we refer to it
internally basically it means when we're
not using data proc we turn it off
that's a very simple premise and this
presentation really talks about how we
do that so there is a blog post the link
at the bottom which is from Google that
explains exactly how to do this it's a
flexible way to deploy hive on cloud
beta proc and the way it works is you
can imagine you might have multiple
clients that actually want to use hive
running upon data proc so that might be
spark clients it may be MapReduce
clients so in this diagram here you'll
see we have two of these transient
clusters or ephemeral clusters as Google
call them I took this this diagram from
the blog post actually and each of those
clusters is running hive hive massage
service and it runs a component called
cloud sequel proxy which is Google
provided component
that allows the hive service running on
that ephemeral cluster to connect to a
hive meta store and that hive meta store
is running in cloud sequel Google's
cloud sequel offering and specifically
we use my sequel the data itself that we
process and we store is stored in Google
Cloud storage in our storage bucket we
don't store the data on the cluster
itself because as always saying when
we're not using those clusters we want
to get rid of them obviously we need the
data data to persist so we used Google
Cloud storage buckets in order to do
that so we offer transient clusters for
both of those types of people and groups
of users that we talked about before so
our data engineers and data scientists
we group all the things we deploy into
components we have a component we call
Data Platform this specifically is what
I work on and what we provide so our
data engineers are these short-lived
clusters so clusters that you spend up
to do a specific piece of work and then
you shut down when you're not using it
the way we do that is we allow our data
in the engineer's to provision clusters
via a series of custom airflow operators
that we wrote ourselves and so the our
data engineers use air flow as an
interface to create these clusters and
create their ETL jobs and then shut the
clusters down by using clusters for a
single use for a single job that
provides a great advantage to us because
we can actually label those cluster
resources according to what they are
actually going to be used for okay so a
data engineer might be doing some work
around dimension processing or
transaction aggregation or future
generation something like that if we can
label what that cluster is actually
useful we can actually get fine-grained
cost analysis of how much it actually
cost us to carry out those functions and
you'll see that a little bit later
finally we use a feature called
scheduled deletion this is something
that Google provide it's an option when
you create a data prop cluster that
allows you
to specify an amount of time that the
cluster should be idle for before Google
will automatically shut it down for you
which is really handli handy typically
we set this to 30 minutes
I think minimum time you can set it to
is 10 minutes but basically as soon as
the cluster is idle it's not being used
anymore Google will shut that down on
our behalf and the way they do that so
this is the command to actually create a
cluster and there is an option which is
max idle you've set that to whatever
duration you you need and it will shut
it down for you when it's not being used
you'll see it's in beta at the moment
it's been in beta for quite a long time
but if you went on or went to the
session yesterday Chris Crosby's session
somebody asked about this and they
basically said yes he's effectively been
GA for a long time they just haven't got
around to switching off the the beta
side yet but it's there we've been using
for a long time and it's being very
successful for us okay so that was
talking about the clusters that we
provide to our vector engineers now I'll
talk a little bit about data scientists
now they have a slightly differently to
our data engineers they will need to
carry out ad hoc analyses and for that
reason we always need to have clusters
available for them to do their work it
takes two or three minutes to spin up a
data proc cluster so what we never want
to do is leave our data scientists data
scientists sitting around waiting for a
cluster to spin up we need to give them
much more immediate access to that so
what would provide for them is auto
scaling clusters these are clusters that
will increase that where the number of
nodes will increase as the load on those
clusters increases so the more users
that are using it the bigger those
clusters will get I'll talk a little bit
on the next slide about how we actually
do that we also offer an Jupiter so
every single one of our data scientists
has the ability to visit a portal that
we provide and spin up their own
dedicated Jupiter notebook running
inside a kubernetes pod that we manage
on their behalf so there's no need for a
data scientist to install anything on
their machine
we provide it for them all they need is
a browser enabled that will enable them
to use Jupiter and of course within
Jupiter that offers Python and our so
our data Sciences have the option of
using Python or R for the stuff that
they're doing ok so a slide specific to
auto scaling clusters so you may be
aware that Google have got a feature I
think it's in beta at the moment an auto
scaling feature we're not actually using
that we'd be we actually built our own
tool which we call tied Bell which will
actually provide auto scaling for us and
the way it works is it monitors cluster
use like utilization via the yarn API
that every cluster has and if it notices
that memory pressure is getting a bubble
certain threshold it will start to add
more nodes into that cluster dynamically
it uses preemptable knows to do that or
our preemptable nodes date sprach is
built upon google's compute engine
service and they've gone offering
compute engine called preemptable
machines and what they are are they're
their standard VMs however they do they
allow Google when they need data sent
data sense of capacity to take that away
from what they're being useful so that
Google will actually take those down
away from us with about a five-minute
warning
but that means they're really Welsh
Welsh ed you'll to two systems which are
resilient to clusters going away and
SPARC is really resilient to that so
it's great for us to use these
preemptable nodes the main benefit is
obviously they're a heck of a lot
cheaper so I saw on a slide yesterday
from the data proper team that you can
get up to 80% cost savings just through
using preemptable nodes so that's pretty
much why we use them we do expect to
replace ty Bell and fairly near future
with data blocks own auto scaling
feature that's currently in beta and
aside from that I think last week that
also announced a new feature which is
currently in alpha which is called
flex enhance flexible mode I think it is
the FM and what that will allow you to
do is make it a lot easy to use
preemptable nodes because what actually
does is persist the states of the jobs
to HDFS before those nodes actually get
shut down so it's really we do have some
issues with preemptable nodes obviously
if it knows going away when their job is
running that's not great but this new
EFM features should be really valuable
for us and I could see Michaela in the
back nodding so I think if you want to
know anything about it Michaela in the
back knows a lot more about it than I do
okay so I said we use graph honor for
visualizing monitoring data and that's
this is a screenshot from graph honor so
this shows activity across our whole
estate across our data broker state
parliament over a 24-hour period what
we're looking at here is the blue line
is the number of nodes that we actually
have active on on data proc at a
particular point in time so you see when
we actually took this screenshot we had
105 those currently active at that time
the yellow line is the number of primary
workers that means the non preemptable
nodes that we have running and the red
the red shade there at the bottom is the
number of preemptions that actually
occur so this is the number of times in
a day that Google will take compute
resources away from us okay so this one
talked a little bit about how our data
scientists actually work on this on this
infrastructure so typically a data
scientist will require the ability to do
ad hoc analysis so carrying out
investigations upon the data that we
provide in that common data model that I
talked about earlier they'll do that
upon our auto-scaling clusters because
that's that's actually why providing us
that's their reason for existence and we
also encourage our data scientists use
sample data sets rather than full data
sets for doing exploratory work for
model training and things like that
the reason being that if they're using
full data sets a it's going to cost us
more
because we're going to be spitting up
more nose to do it and we do have a
danger that if many data scientists are
using a cluster at any one time it is
possible for a particular job to max out
that cluster and that will impact
anybody else using it so we do encourage
them to use sample datasets wherever
possible so when they've done that
they've done like where they've decided
on some work that they need to do we
would then encourage them to take that
work that they've done in Jupiter and
produced and turn that into a job that
can be run on one of the short-lived
clusters that I talked about earlier so
the difference between our short-lived
clusters which have the scheduled
deletion option and our long live
clusters that use auto-scaling
so they use the auto scaling clusters
for investigation and they'll run
production ready jobs upon our
short-lived clusters so what we're
looking at here is there's a report that
we built in Google Data studio so this
sits on top of our billing data that
Google provides to us and that billing
data is stored in bigquery so the number
of things just want to draw your
attention to here when we actually use
these data proc clusters we use labeling
upon upon those clusters to tell us
various things about what they're going
to be used for so for example the data
we can slice and dice this data by the
client but the date that the cluster is
being used for because every cluster is
dedicated to a particular client the
project that's been used in the
components now what do I mean by a
component so I talked earlier about how
we we have our Data Platform component
that we have today for engineers we have
our analyze platform that we offer to
data scientists so we can slice and dice
the data by those two things we can
filter slice and dice by the Machine
type and the number of nodes so this is
really useful because we can actually
see we allow our data engineers to know
the cost of actually running specific
jobs and if they they can contest that
using different node configurations and
see whether it's cost effective or not
to actually use more nodes
in that cluster we finally this is this
is a real useful part of it what we've
allowed people to do is label the
specific workload that they're using
that cluster for so as I talked about
before a data engineer might be doing
things like dimension processing or
transaction aggregation or feature
generation and if they actually label
that cluster and we give them tools to
actually do that we can actually get
very specific cost cost things about how
it how much it costs to actually run
that job so you see in this example I'm
filtering on I use the word workload
over workload earlier we have to call it
a purpose so I'm filtering on a purpose
of smoke test so this is a test that we
run across our whole estate what it does
it's very simple it spins up a data
block buster it runs some jobs upon it
and then it shops that cluster down
after so we can actually get a cost for
how much actually how much it costs to
actually run one of those smoke tests so
there's an example here you can see
actually crosses 18 cents every time
well roughly 18 cents every time we spin
up a cluster run a couple of jobs and
shut it down so that sort of
fine-grained analysis is fantastic for
us we can never do that we were running
Hadoop in our own data center because it
was shared between multiple clients
multiple engineers here we're actually
having single-use clusters and we can
actually get the cost of spinning one of
those up which is really contagious you
can see over the past few months we look
in the bottom right hand corner that's
cost there's about a hundred and
forty-two dollars over the past five
years five months just running that
particular smoke test okay so in a
single day
what do we actually do so look at the
lower numbers first of all we run these
these services for 35 clients currently
that's about half of our client base I
said we're about halfway through our
cloud migration so we've got 35 35
clients running in GCP
and approximately 300 terabytes stored
for that before those
clients on any particular day we use
about 17,000 hours of compute engine
time our particular hour is using a
computer and using a core in a compute
engine instance for one hour so 17,000
plus hours in any particular day thanks
to our auto scaling feature and thanks
to our short-lived clusters which we
encourage our data engineers to spin up
as and when they need we actually on the
particularly day we measured this we
created two thousand nine hundred and
seventy one nodes as physical physical
virtual machines running compute engine
being used for the purposes of data proc
five hundred twenty five of them got
preempted so I'll give you some sort of
indication about the preemption race
that we're seeing from using preemptable
nodes are though it's brockless auto
scale clusters so a whole lot 17,000
hours crosses approximately seven
thousand six hundred dollars a day I'll
let you figure out whether that's that
expensive or not we're pretty happy well
that's costing us because as I say that
cost is spread across those thirty five
clients and we have approximately 175
data scientists on any particular day
using Jupiter on our short-lived
clusters accessing that data this in in
Google storage buckets so this is the
money slide in more ways than one
this depicts the cost of actually
providing the services that we provide
to just one single client over a
12-month period so I didn't include the
y axis because the numbers themselves
are not that important
but I think you see the profile is what
I won't really want to draw your
attention to and you'll see in a last
year we had a huge downturn the actual
expenditure of cost to serve this client
and the reason for that is very simply
that's when we introduced transient
clusters for this client so a very real
depiction of the cost saving and we're
getting from using transient clusters
the spiky workloads that you see over to
the right-hand side
that have increased over the past three
or four months that's because our
analysts are data scientists now getting
much more familiar with the platform and
they're starting to run much more
production-ready workloads on this and
spiky because we're encouraging to use
those short-lived clusters that I talked
about earlier so a lot of people ask you
is okay that's great you're using data
Brock for things like that seems to be
pretty pretty successful but you're on
GCP why not just use bigquery I've had a
lot of people from Google asking me the
same thing this week as well so there's
a few reasons GCP is our preferred cloud
provider but that doesn't mean what
always going to be running and stuff on
GCP it's not available everywhere we do
have clients in China and in Russia and
we do find in some certain cases that
our clients may want to dictate the
cloud provided to us some people we've
found are actually not happy with on GCP
and in those cases we have to provide in
a different provider so basically we
strive to be cloud portable but we're
not cloud agnostic we want to be able to
move our workloads across across
different clouds and making a bet on
open source technologies like Hadoop and
spark has been a driver of that and
other big bet that we made technically
has been around kubernetes as well so
adopting those open source technologies
hopefully will allow us to move our
workloads of Crush different clouds in
the future and obviously the anthos
announcement a couple of days ago is
going to be very interesting to us all
that said we do use bigquery for some
things I talked about how we use it for
our billing data that drives the report
that you saw a couple of slides back we
also have some direct consumer offerings
that we have as well so we have a
whiskey receipt scanning mobile app
called who you it's only in the UK at
the moment but basically it provides
lottery rewards to customers who want to
actually scan their receipts and all the
data for that gets stored in bigquery as
well because that's a direct consumer
offering it's essentially the client is
done humbly ourselves so we can host
that we
everyone and we choose to put that in
bigquery I want to talk a little bit
about the solution architecture that we
have within core technology this is
essentially the architecture that we
deploy for each of our clients so the
base component is something we call
network that basic consists of a big V
PC network and cloud DNS so we provision
DNS a records and cname records for that
clients on top of that we deploy a
component we call base this provides an
external proxy so that we can get to the
outside world should we need to an SSH
gateway so that we as engineers can
actually get on to the infrastructure
itself should we need to for
investigation for maintenance anything
like that and we also provide a single
sign-on authentication proxy as well and
that's all part of our base component on
top of that we have a component we call
hive meta store and this is what I was
talking about a bit earlier in the talk
where we use Google's cloud sequel
offering to host the hive meta store
that will be get used by our transients
ephemeral clusters so that is a
component we deploy on its own
essentially it is a my sequel database
running in class sequel and some of that
we have a data platform component which
is the thing I said I worked on this is
where we provide short-lived clusters to
our data engineers we do that through a
combination of data proc storage buckets
air flow and we also provide Jupiter
instances to our data engineer as well
on top of that our analyst platform I
talked about before again we're using
transient clusters we're using our auto
scale clusters using our tied Bell tool
and we provide Jupiter running on top of
kubernetes - to our data scientist as
well we also run our various products on
top of this as well
so that's our architecture the way we
actually deployed that is across two
separate projects to separate GCP
projects we have a project dedicated for
hosting our runtime infrastructure and
our project dedicated to hosting data
essentially so state so why do we do
that it prevents the provides quite a
lot of advantages actually so we could
keep our long live State in a dedicated
project and keep our short lived runtime
in a separate project and really the key
to this is segregation so segregation of
permissions around I am segregation of
data retention privacy policies and it
also makes it easier for disaster
recovery as well so essentially we take
the architecture that I showed you a
couple of slides back and we deployed
that across those two projects that we
dedicate per clients so essentially we
have multiple instances of this
architecture running across GCP estate
so why do we do it why do we why do we
have this single tenant deployment model
previously when we run everything on
premises in our own data center we
didn't have a single tenant deployment
model we had very big clusters and we
shared them between multiple clients now
we're in the cloud we can we can use a
single tenant deployment model and the
reason really is it's one of segregation
again really it's keeping things
separate that don't need to be in the
same place it's a lot simpler for us to
assign access for clients to actually
access our infrastructure we can just we
can control that with the natural
boundary that a GCP project provides
it's a lot simpler for us to operate we
don't need to worry about using Kerberos
or anything like that cost transparency
is a big factor for us if we want to
actually see the cost of serving a
particular clients it's very easy to do
that because the billing data is all
kanabi group talk to a particular
project or a couple of projects so we
can see very easily the cost of actually
serving a client and you saw that on on
an earlier slide the other big advantage
that it provides is the ability to scale
from zero so what do I mean by that if
you think about how we work we we will
sign a client to do some work from them
we provision to two projects on their
behalf at that point it's essentially
nothing in those projects there's no
data
there's no runtime components and not
none of our data scientists or our data
engineers will actually have access to
it so literally we start we have nothing
it makes it a lot easier to scale that
up as than when we need we never had the
capability to do that when we were on
premises because we were using share
clusters so we had to provision massive
clusters in advance of actually signing
our clients before we actually know that
we were going to have them so makes it a
lot easier for us to provide
infrastructure to brand-new clients
that's really the meat of the talk
talking about transient clusters
autoscale clusters and how and the
architecture that we use to provide that
to our clients now what I've done is
provides a project on github that really
demonstrates a lot of how we do this so
what this is is a project that will use
terraform code to deploy the parts of
the architecture that I just deployed
that I just demonstrated and
specifically what it will do is deploy
those transient clusters for us so this
is a screenshot from the readme that's
part of that project essentially if you
want to run this all you need to do is
clone the repo run g-cloud init which
will establish which project you
actually want to which GCP projects you
want to deploy us into you enable a
couple of services specify the project
you have to create a cloud storage
bucket which is what terraform will use
to store its state so terraform needs to
keep a record of what is being deployed
it does that in a storage bucket and
then there's a make file in there which
will actually show you how to act which
will actually deploy this on your behalf
so you could clone that create a project
run run the apply that whole thing
should take about five minutes I don't
want to demo it today
because we don't want stare at command
line for about five minutes but if you
want to see how this works and how we
set this up using terraform this is a
really good way to do it and when you're
finished you could just run make destroy
and I'll try it tear the whole thing
down again one thing you can do with
terraform is actually visualize all the
components that it's going to deploy for
you and this is the output of running
that terraform graph command the command
in the bottom right hand corner shows
you exactly what command you need to run
which will generate this graph for you
and just to call out a few things on
here the yellow boxes are the other
network components that it will deploy
for you so we deploy a network a sub
Network and various firewalls that
enable the different components thoughts
with each other
we deploy a Google Storage bucket which
will actually store the data that's
that's the way that's the purple
component you can see at the bottom the
red components are the hive meta store
as the cloud sequel instance that is
roasting the hive meta store and a
sequel use that enables us to access
that the blue are the ephemeral clusters
themselves the transient clusters we
create this project will create two of
them for you both of them pointing out
that shared hive meta store which really
is the crux of this presentation to be
honest and then on top of that the green
boxes are some jobs that we run on top
of those clusters and as I say deploying
this whole thing I'm running those jobs
Tech's four or five minutes and they can
tear it all down again afterwards so
it's a really good demonstration of how
we do what we do and how you can use
these are ephemeral clusters using a
shared hive meta store so before I came
out here all right I said I worked there
too about 25 so I sent an email round to
everybody I work with they said like can
you just give me a grab bag of things I
can talk about at the end which will
come under the banner of lessons learned
so here's a few things that my colleague
sent to me I'm just going to go through
them one by one so this shared hive
matter store is great because it allows
us to use these ephemeral clusters but
it does make upgrades very difficult
because we got to coordinate
teams of data scientists teams of data
our engineers and our infrastructure
teams to make sure that we're not
stepping on anybody's toes when we try
to upgrade that stuff we have to upgrade
everything at the same time we're
working with Google to make that a lot
little bit easier we're hoping to anyway
but yeah it's a bit of a pain point for
us at the moment we recommend if you're
going to do this you pegged at
approximate it specific minor release
you don't have to do that you can
specify a particular data proper j'en a
major release version if you want but we
have seen that doing that and then when
will will deploy the latest minor
release for you we have seen occasions
where when the minor release changes
some of the scripts that we run some of
the initialization scripts do break so
be careful without peg it to a minor
release if you can stack driver logs can
become very chatty very grow very
quickly and they can become very
expensive stack drive is not cheap so I
know if you use in a lot and you're
throwing lots of logs into it so use log
exclusions within stack drive you can
and configure your log4j properties so
when it's not being too chatty I said
we're using terraform and we are it's
been great for us and but be aware that
terraform providers the google-specific
terraform provided generally likes
what's available in the sdk so you might
be using features in G cloud for example
they're currently not supported in
terraform we've experienced that a few
times and we have made upstream commits
to the terraformable provider but it has
been a bit of a pain for us in shared
clusters users can easily crush the
master nodes where driver runs on the
master so change the default deploy mode
to cluster if you're familiar with using
spark you have to deployment modes
client and cluster where we're using
where we have shake shared clusters it's
quite easy for one data scientist to run
a nefarious job which actually brings
the whole cluster to its knees so for
that reason we run into run with a
deployment mode of cluster and you
minimize the chances of that happening
more lessons learned
you're an application masters can fail
if scheduled on preemption preempted
nodes so I explained how preempted nodes
are all about how Google could actually
take that resource away from us so
running masters on that is not a good
idea you can get around this by using
node labeling and I believe is also a
data prop config option which is come
out which prevents this from happening
so use that and I couldn't see Micaela
in the back nodding as well so happy to
use that the default spark configured
data prop can cause an individual to max
out the cluster yes so we're using these
share clusters if you don't tune the the
initial configuration options it we were
seeing particular jobs that are dead
sound since they're running we're
actually bring clusters to the knee so
be careful with the default memory
configuration you apply to those jobs
users need the spark and yarn UI's but
hard to make secure and available via
our authentication proxy anyone that use
spark will tell you that the yarn and
the spark you eyes are incredibly useful
for diagnosing issues within those jobs
particularly if you've got skew in your
Sparta jobs so we've had a lot of hassle
making those UI is available via the
authentic single sign-on authentication
proxy that we have so something to be
aware of make sure you get those working
as early as possible
kondeh is a useful tool for building
consistent Python environments across
data Barack and Jupiter books so we need
to make sure that the same Python
libraries that we deploy to date
approach on the same that we use in in
either Jupiter notebooks as well condor
is a useful tool for doing that and
finally GCS retention policies on
temporary datasets so we provide
specific temporary areas so Google
storage buckets that our data scientists
can use for temporary storage and you
can set retention policies on those so
that data gets cleared down after a
certain amount of time we actually saw
an occasion last week where the usage on
one of our particular clients jumps from
17 terabytes to 36 terabytes
overnight and it's basically because one
of our data scientists had dropped a
load the data into a least Tempest
that happened on a Friday by the end of
Monday that it automatically get clipped
got cleaned up again because of the
retention policy they were put on those
temporary areas right I am done thank
you very much for attending everybody
ubiquitous Ida but slide about providing
feedback if you could I certainly really
appreciate it
I've got about ten minutes left so if
anybody wants to stick around I'll take
questions and thank you once again for
coming along I hope it was useful
[Applause]
[Music]